lawrence fishburne and hugo weaving
weren't invited back into the matrix and
we think we know why the matrix
resurrections is finally here these are
the questions it left us
[Music]
at
with
lawrence fishburne's work in the
original three matrix films it's some
iconic stuff the wise man leading figure
of the human resistance fish burns
morpheus as a finely tuned performance
he comes off perfectly as a charismatic
figure to believe in at the same time
that he conveys his own and yielding
faith in the prophecy of the one
fishburn's morpheus does show up in the
matrix resurrections but only in a very
meta fashion with clips from the first
movie projected at times around neo's
new reality we thought elements from
your past
might help ease you into the present
nothing comforts anxiety like
little nostalgia old morpheus clips may
be a vivid stand-in for nostalgia but
the arrangement leaves us wondering why
not bring in the original morpheus
himself for a return of his own
alongside keanu reeves and carrie and
mars this isn't a knock on yaya
abdulmatine ii who subs in for fishburn
as a new version of morpheus he rocks
some amazing outfits and speaks all the
familiar matrix jargon with just as much
flair as fishburn did but longtime
matrix fans still might be disappointed
by the absence of the original morpheus
so why did this happen in 2020 while
resurrections was in production fishburn
confirmed his lack of involvement with
the movie to entertainment tonight
saying i have not been asked to join
them which is fine i am hopeful that it
will be wonderful and it will satisfy
audiences and that people will love it
abdul mateen apparently taking over the
role implied in his own interviews that
his morpheus is a different being
entirely in october 2021 the actor told
entertainment weekly this is definitely
a different iteration of the character i
play a character who's definitely aware
of the history of the matrix and the
history of morpheus this character is on
a journey of self-discovery there's a
lot in our story that's about growth
defining your own path morpheus isn't
exempt from that now that the movie is
out we know what he's talking about the
real morpheus played by lawrence
fishburne is assumed to be dead by the
time of the matrix resurrections which
is set after a substantial time jump the
new morpheus of this matrix is a program
designed based on neo's memories a new
digital character based on both the
flesh and blood morpheus and agent smith
who also happens to be mixed for some of
the old code for agent smith when asked
why the movie went this route keanu
reeves told the uk outlet unilad that it
was a purely creative decision from
director co-writer and matrix originator
lana wachowski reeves said speaking with
lana about that it was just creatively
where she wanted to go with the
production and the story co-star carrie
anne mosk confirmed that saying there's
an evolution that happened for lana with
the story and we're here serving that
it's happening exactly as before
well not exactly
[Applause]
morpheus isn't the only character who
was recast for resurrections hugo
weaving's evil matrix agent smith is
also represented in this movie by a
different actor in this case mine turned
to star jonathan groff unlike fishburn
weaving is on record saying that he was
asked to return but there was a
scheduling conflict that prevented his
involvement in january 2020 he told
timeout london i thought i could do both
and it took eight weeks to work out that
the dates would work i was in touch with
lana wachowski but in the end she
decided that the dates weren't going to
work so would sorted the dates and then
she sort of changed her mind they're
pushing on a head without me of course
smith's not his usual self in this movie
either we learn early in resurrections
that game developer thomas anderson is
working for a younger cocky boss who is
pushing him to revisit the matrix video
games that helped build the company as a
movie unfolds that boss finds himself in
the middle of a major shootout picking
up a gun and revealing himself to be a
new and improved smith for agent smith
the reinventure makes a bit more sense
to morpheus from his taking over of
every being in the matrix and the
sequels to even invading the real world
the identity of this rogue program has
always been a more fluid thing
yes me
resurrections drives that point home
multiple times just like in the old
movies his fate is inextricably linked
to that of neo and the two of them
literally being codependent co-workers
at the beginning of the movie is a great
way of showing it
you can be forgiven if you don't
recognize jaded plinkett smith reprising
her role as naiobi after a substantial
time jump at this point in the movie's
real world her days of leaping around
doing gunfu are well behind her although
it has been 20 years since the events of
the original films bugs explains that
that's just the time that's passed in
the matrix in the real world of the
movie 60 years have passed which
accounts for the apparent death of
morpheus this also explains why a
character like lexi is a grandchild of
roland former captain of the mjolnir now
a general niobi has become harder more
bitter and doesn't suffer false which in
her mind seems to include bugs one of
the film's new characters who seems to
value passion over patience after more
than 60 years of fighting this seemingly
endless battle who can blame her
after the matrix revolutions no one
thought would see a sequel to the series
that continued the story of the first
three movies now resurrections has us
wondering if there might be more sequels
on the way for this new era of the
matrix if there aren't it certainly
isn't for lack of trying the ending of
matrix resurrections is filled with all
sorts of indications where the franchise
could be headed from the survival of the
analyst to trinity's new superpowered
status when the end credits roll we see
the words to matrix resurrects which
could be teasing the name or concept for
the next film a sequel could obviously
explore trinity's newfound powers much
in the same way that we loaded expanded
our understanding of neo's abilities as
the one it could also follow trinity and
neo as they take the wheel of the matrix
and work to build a kinder gentler
reality with rainbows in the skies even
if there never is another matrix movie
resurrections could likely stand on its
own as an endpoint for the series the
film's story is relatively
self-contained and by the end it leaves
off with an uplifting message it might
be as close to a happily ever after
ending as any matrix fan could expect as
always the movie's performance will
dictate whether the story continues but
if resurrection is a hit there are
certainly places this story could go
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]